ANTHONY MAYS: Welcome to
"Engineering Everyday Equity."
My name is Anthony
D. Mays, and I'm
a software engineer on the
data visualization team
here at Google.
Today we have Lea Coligado.
So nice to have you
here today, Lea.
LEA COLIGADO: Thanks so
much for having me, Anthony.
ANTHONY MAYS: In
today's episode,
we're going to talk
about how to build
inclusive practices into your
product development process.
And we're going to talk over the
next few episodes specifically
about the design process
and the design sprint,
and how you can think about
inclusion at that stage.
And today we're
specifically going
to talk about the planning
phase and about how
to think about
equity, diversity,
and inclusion from day one.
So Lea, it's so great to have
you here to talk about this,
and to share your knowledge
and expertise with us today.
If you can just take a
moment to tell me a little
bit about your background.
LEA COLIGADO: So I
actually just came back
from giving a speech to
Google Women Engineers Summit
on intersectional feminism.
I am a software engineer on
Google's local search team.
I'm also the founder of
a diversity blog called
"Women in Silicon Valley."
I do a lot of
diversity inclusion
work because I'm the daughter
of Vietnamese and Filipino
refugees.
And actually, for a
long time, I didn't
want that to identify
me, because I felt
like I was punished for it.
But now I see my diversity
as essential to bringing
my cultural identity
to work and making sure
that the people who are
like me and look like me
are being included
into product decisions.
And so I'd like to learn more
about your background, what
motivates you to do this work.
ANTHONY MAYS: Sure.
And thanks for
sharing that with me.
As a black man and
as a Christian,
I could really
identify with some
of the things that you
were talking about,
diversity inclusion
every day, both in terms
of the products that
I help to build,
and in the interactions that
I have within the tech space.
Sometimes it can be
difficult as a black man when
I, for instance, need
to proactively think
about how visible my badge
is to ensure that I'm not
more aggressively badge
checked than other people are
for being on campus.
And then there are
times when I need
to worry about or think
about maybe disparaging jokes
that someone might make about
my faith as a Christian,
or about religion in general.
And so as I think
about those things,
it drives me to want to
think about these topics
and how to make
sure that tech is
more diverse and
inclusive in terms of,
again, how we
build our products,
and how we work with
each other as colleagues.
LEA COLIGADO: I
think before we talk
a more about equity
diversity inclusion,
we should probably try setting
up and defining our parameters.
ANTHONY MAYS: Yeah,
that's a good idea.
So first, let's
talk about equity.
Equity denotes
fairness, and makes
sure everyone has access
to the same opportunities.
In that fairness,
equity recognizes
that because advantages
and obstacles exist,
everyone doesn't start
from the same place.
Pursuing equity begins
by acknowledging
that unequal playing field
and continues to course
correct and address
the imbalance.
The next is diversity.
Diversity, by definition,
is about variety,
the presence of difference
within a given setting.
Studies show that
a team that hails
from a diversity of backgrounds,
beliefs, and experiences
can approach the same issue
from many different angles.
So by building diversity into
your organization and dog food
process, it will help
guarantee a wider base is
considered for your product.
And the last is inclusion.
Inclusion isn't just about
the presence of diversity.
It goes farther
to ensure everyone
feels valued and welcomed.
As Verna Myers, a thought
leader in the inclusion strategy
space, puts it, "Diversity is
being invited to the party.
Inclusion is being
asked to dance."
LEA COLIGADO: So would
you say that means equity
is about switching
who takes the lead?
ANTHONY MAYS: Well,
I'd say it's more
about ensuring
that everyone feels
empowered to do the asking.
So now that we've
laid the groundwork
for these fundamental
concepts, let's
talk about the design process.
And as I think about
the design process,
there's a story
that comes to mind
about this app that was in the
process of being developed.
And it involved allowing
people to silence
their phones by tapping on it
while it was in their pocket.
Now as a guy, I don't see
any problem with this, but as
a woman, do you see any issues?
LEA COLIGADO: Yeah, very few of
my pants have pockets sewn in.
ANTHONY MAYS: All it took
was one woman in the room
to identify an issue that
could have potentially impacted
50% of their
potential user base.
And so as you think
about the design process,
are there things that
you've encountered
in your past experience?
LEA COLIGADO: Yeah, I've
seen a lot of the effects,
positive and negative,
of design thinking.
For example, when I was
a student at Stanford,
I took this awesome
senior project class
where all the teams were
commissioned to build apps.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
LEA COLIGADO: And so because
most of the engineers,
if not all, were Stanford
students, a lot of the apps
we produced were social
media or marketplace
apps, which assume things like
leisure, time for leisure,
or disposable income.
ANTHONY MAYS: Right.
LEA COLIGADO: So
these apps fizzled,
while the teams that tried
to represent the community
outside of Stanford and
do field studies actually
addressed real community needs.
Another example I can
think of in the real world
is when I joined Google
full-time, a startup popped up
in San Francisco that
claimed to replace the mom
and pop corner shops that we
often see on street corners.
Clearly, little design thinking
was infused into this app,
because otherwise
they would have
known that San
Francisco has a really
long, controversial relationship
with gentrification,
and by claiming to gentrify
these mom and pop stores that
were often run and founded
by people of color,
this app crashed and burned,
because it got a lot of uproar.
ANTHONY MAYS: Ow!
Yeah, I can totally
imagine that happening.
All right.
So we've talked
about a few examples.
Obviously, we don't want to
repeat those same mistakes.
So how about we talk about
building inclusiveness
into our own hypothetical
app and getting that started?
LEA COLIGADO: It sounds good.
Tell me more about this app.
ANTHONY MAYS: I have an app idea
for something called Scholar.
And it's an app that connects
matriculating high school
students with colleges and
scholarship opportunities
based upon campus size,
preferences, study programs,
things of that nature.
So for me, I care
about this a lot
because, as confusing
as it was for me,
I'd like to take
that confusion out
of the process for the next
generation of technologists who
are looking to get
into tech and pursue
their educational dreams.
How can I start
thinking about inclusion
from the very beginning
of designing this app
that I want to build?
LEA COLIGADO: Well, one
thing we want to do,
Anthony, is create a
challenge statement
to build the inclusivity
into our app.
What do we have currently
for our statement?
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
So in 2018, I want
to build an app that
connects college
students with colleges
and demystifies the
application process.
LEA COLIGADO: That's
a really good start.
How about let's take it
further and say something like,
in 2018, we want to
launch an app that
matches colleges and demystifies
the college search process
for first generation students.
ANTHONY MAYS: Sure.
Cool.
All right.
So now that I think we have
a good working challenge
statement, how can I
ensure that the team
stays focused on executing?
LEA COLIGADO: Well, there
are a couple of things.
Let's make sure that
stakeholders and execs
are all on board to build
inclusivity into our project.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
LEA COLIGADO: Have them
reiterate to the team
that it's a value
that they share.
The challenge statement
is actually not enough.
So we're going to
need team members
to reinforce each other,
reiterate each other,
and keep each other accountable.
One thing to note,
make sure we're not
putting the burden
of representing
a certain marginalized
group on someone
on your team who represents
that marginalized background.
So for example, as a
woman of color who's often
been the only woman
of color in many teams
I've worked on in
tech, I was usually
the go-to for all questions
pertaining to either women
or to Asian people.
So while I'm happy to
help, it can be difficult
bearing the brunt of
representing all women
or all Asian people.
ANTHONY MAYS: How
do you personally
advocate for people who are
perhaps different than you are?
LEA COLIGADO:
Everyone should just
care about diversity
inclusion at face value.
But unfortunately, that's
not always the case.
So as a woman of
color, what's helped
me is when an ally
steps up to the plate
and explains the benefits of
including my demographic, when
it was too
emotionally burdensome
or draining for me to explain
why my demographic should
be included when it
wasn't at face value.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
So there's ally-ship.
Are there are some
other things that I
can do for the team to
make sure that we're
continuing to think on this?
LEA COLIGADO: One thing
is lightning talks.
We want to make
sure that everyone
who is present at the
sprint is diverse.
And so how are some
ways that we can
ensure the building of your
app and that the people
in the room building it
reflect our user base.
ANTHONY MAYS: That's
a good question.
Well, the first thing that
comes off the top of my head
is the fact that--
well, the challenge statement,
where I want to build this
app for first generation
college students.
So it probably would help if I
had one or two first generation
college students talking
about their experience
and about how they
were able to connect
with schools and scholarships.
So sound good to you?
LEA COLIGADO: Precisely.
That's a great idea.
ANTHONY MAYS: So let's just
summarize real quickly.
We talked about the meaning
of equity, diversity,
and inclusion.
We also talked about what it
means to have a great challenge
statement.
We talked about executive buy-in
and the importance of support
from leadership.
We talked about ally-ship,
which is really important.
And lastly, we talked about
how to hold inclusive lightning
talks and about having people
from diverse backgrounds who
can share their perspectives
and experiences.
Thank you for watching.
If you'd like to continue
the work of building equity,
diversity, and inclusion
into your company or product,
check out the link in
the description below.
If you have questions, leave
those in the comments as well.
And lastly, make
sure to stay tuned
for our next
episode, where we're
going to talk about
the understanding
phase of the design process.
And let me leave you
with this last thing.
If you do not
intentionally include,
you will
unintentionally exclude.
[MUSIC PLAYING]